for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
University com
thank you and enjoy previously we talked
about how physical and chemical
properties of elements are based on
their electron configurations in this
video series we're going to talk about
how we can use the periodic table to
note trends in particular properties and
we're gonna note these trends up and
down and across the periodic table and
this is really really useful so which
properties will we actually talk about
we're going to talk about atomic size
which is basically atomic radius I'm
gonna talk about ionization energy which
is often abbreviated ie we're gonna talk
about electron affinity which is often
abbreviated EA will also talk about
ionic size or ionic radius and we'll
talk about electronegativity which is
often abbreviated EE n you'll notice
next to electronegativity I have a
little asterisk there and the reason why
is that electronegativity is not a
property of a standalone or single or
solo atom instead it's a property of a
bonded atom and that's a distinction
we'll get into later one thing I really
want you to take home from this though
is that we're talking about trends in
these properties and when we say trends
we're sort of implying that there are
certain exceptions to these trends just
to give you an idea of kind of what I'm
talking about think about a business a
business's goal is to profit and so I've
got this graph here of profit over time
let's imagine that each of these little
points here is a month you know oh and
then the corresponding point in the
y-axis would be the profit that month so
if someone asked you what the trend was
as far as profit over time you would
probably say that the profit is
increasing as time
goes on right profit increases with time
right because generally speaking this
this is sort of almost like a line going
up like this but you'll know that there
are certain exceptions right for
instance this point right here right to
this point right here it increased right
profit increase there and then increased
again and then increased again but then
here it's kind of like from that point
to that point it's pretty much a
straight line and then we go up again
and then we come down right here that
point right there I'll should change the
color that I circled that way right
there and that month profit dropped
right and over here we'll notice that
profit dropped as well but overall the
overall trend is that profit increased
over time so what I'm trying to say is
that when as you watch this video series
keep in mind that everything that we
talked about with these properties is a
trend that there are exceptions anyway I
hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying